to where a crime has occurred we're
talking about burglaries robberies and
homicides the i-team looked at zip codes
across the valley and what we found may
surprise you
as leadership we're constantly looking
at how do we effectively deploy the
officers that we have and we do that
through data it's data now readily
available online that las vegas metro
police says helps send resources to
fight against crime the 8 news now
i-team crunching those numbers finding
the top reported crime for each zip code
in metro's jurisdiction we found that
simple assault where a person threatens
or attempts to injure another nearly
three quarters of our 75 zip codes have
simple assault as their top crime for
last year certain areas have been
identified as traditional hot spots or
high crime areas deputy chief nick
farisi says it's no secret the las vegas
strip and areas around it can attract
criminals and their vices metro saying
gangs and pimps create their own
problems when you're living that
lifestyle you're going to be more prone
to becoming a victim of a crime and
specifically a violent crime looking at
violent crime by zip code 89101 had the
most homicide with 17. we're talking
about the area just north of downtown
the most aggravated assaults were in
89115
with
425 reported last year 89109 had the
most sex offenses with 180
when it comes to property crime 89119
had the most burglaries with
548. 89122 saw the most motor vehicle
thefts but 237 and 89109 saw the most
thefts from a motor vehicle with nearly
800 you know it's really hard to catch
every criminal we showed our findings to
frank rudy cooper a law professor at
unlv who studies these trends while it's
certainly important to concentrate on
the strip a lot of our crime is
distributed
not quite evenly but certainly
distribute out into other areas cooper
notes no area of the valley is free of
crime with the drug crisis fueling a lot
of property crime he suggests knowing
what's happening in your neighborhood
that's going to be helpful because the
more information people have the more
they can lobby for having their needs
met in various ways and in some parts of
the community that may be you know less
policing of things like jaywalking and
more policing of you know actual
burglaries or whatever but it just seems
like a lot of people are on edge and
have short fuses the deputy chief says
simple assault as the valley's top crime
is not surprising he says more than half
are domestic violence related an issue
he says metro takes very seriously yeah
these crimes are happening they're
occurring
but our officers are out there our
detectives are out there and doing that
relentless follow-up and we are making
arrests
so right now on eightnewsnow.com and in
our app you can zoom in to your
neighborhood see where homicides
burglaries robberies are happening near
you we've also compiled this list by zip
code and it basically breaks it down for
you so you can check it out and brian i
know you were very interested in this
you said while this story was playing i
find this very interesting i'm going to
hold you to that i do and there's parts
of the country we know where crime is up
but for las vegas a lot of people here
want to know is crime getting better or
worse so if you look at this year to
date so january to august of this year
versus last year crime across the las
vegas valley at least in metro's
jurisdiction is up three percent mainly
driven by property crime so theft of
things over violent crime that's
something affecting a person in addition
to this new tool the deputy chief you
just heard from there says a great way
to learn about what's happening in your
community is to go to those first
tuesdays that metro offers at your local
area command and if you live in
henderson or north las vegas police
there also have similar ways brian for
you to meet with officers we're going to
keep you and your family safe every day
great job with that david thank you